when you're a kid you're told to follow
your dreams jks he's been very hard to
stopping this is the reason why oh my
god they lined up for the quad kill and
that if you try hard enough you'll
succeed the pressure of the timer right
now is 100 saves and gratis faction but
we all know it doesn't always work out
like that and renegades have been
eliminated from this major so hard to be
eliminated from the tournament at this
stage for them and then also in the
fashion that they did oh my god I mean I
wasn't at eco but sometimes you witness
something and it's like a childhood
fantasy coming to life back around the
Smokies still a factor in in
counter-strike we're having a moment
like that right now
going for a believe oh he's gonna get a
- he's gonna find he's gonna sneak
around on the Vice oh no is no it's
turned it he's got two in a USB and now
he has a creek of his own they're trying
to run the bomb to be after years of
grinding the mostly aussie renegades
have finally made it to the upper ash
lines of pro counter-strike they've
proven that their initial success wasn't
a one-off fluke there's still a top team
after their semi-final finish at the
Berlin major and they've got a shiny new
org backing them [ __ ] go win [ __ ] why
not why not us subscribe your favorite
shoe and some beers because the Aussies
are finally contenders
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so Australia has never really been
a top-tier contender in counter-strike
or in any other Eastbourne for that
matter renegades have pretty much been
the country's only team qualifying for
some encounter strikes bigger
tournaments renegades made quarterfinals
for the first time in February of this
year at the Katowice major they followed
that up with their first ever semi-final
finish at the starladder Berlin main in
the quarterfinals renegades faced off
against the undefeated ants and they
didn't just beat them they beat them to
nothing all that stands for versus one
for angry well three angry all season
hangry Norwegians that ready to take
this series against s to push themselves
in to that semi-finals all that stands
in their way
is a loo coming up into the heaven
position looking to get his first peek
he will be denied renegades through to
the semis but one-offs and
counter-strike aren't rare I mean teams
Popoff for a single tournament all the
time
think of ninjas in pyjamas who popped
off at IEM Auckland in 2016 and 2017
it's not just about this one tournament
in this seat
Yaba there's so many competitive teams
any team can come and win one tournament
but the way an IP played really gives
you hope that in the future with this
different approach they can be a
contender at future tournaments as well
but renegades is deep major run wasn't a
fluke they continue to perform finding
another semi-final finish that star
series season 8 there's gonna be a
crossfire setup no matter which way you
look at it one player directly above
Gratus faction one player Nathan sign a
window room those shots we're gonna do
it that works so easily I am very
impressed that renegades into the bumps
like this clean and Austin's gonna
finish it off one kill on the apex it's
just our PK and he's got fire in front
of them and now smoke has nothing to do
at this point if you're off he get a
beautiful head shot but it's not enough
16
12s reading it takedown by telling me
well it took some time the addition of
Lea's and gratis faction turned this fun
group of lads into actual contenders I
think there's always been kind of
personality clashes and the pasta
durations of the team and then when me
and J came in wave and they're like
super chill players we've never rage
we never have like conflicting opinions
on things like we can we're open-minded
so we can agree on most things with
other players and their rise caught the
attention of an org looking to make a
comeback into csgo you to buy the fudge
you don't hey guys nadeshot today we're
in a brand new video hope you guys are
all having a fantastic day this is a
moment that everyone here at our
organization has been waiting for we're
here to talk about auto thieves
answering common strike yes we are
entering Counter Strike and we are doing
it in style let's say we're doing with
the team that we wanted we have agreed
to a trend so for the now-former
renegades roster back in 2017 they
acquired the Brazilian core that
previously played for immortals but
before the team could play a single game
hundred thieves drop the roster due to
controversy surrounding K and G but
luckily for nadeshot things seem to be
different this time we knew from day one
when the conversations started that they
wanted to be a part of a hundred thieves
and it's very important we want them to
be an integral part of our content we
want them to really just feel like
they're a part of our world in all
facets of our business 100 thieves is
new roster have continued to make
Australia proud with another stellar
tournament finish forty seconds left and
JK is turning around and there it is
he's gonna bring down the destruction
right on top of vitality a 16 to to
score line at the end and there in the
grand finals here in Beijing it even
warranted a schooi from the man himself
the boys I am Beijing just beat vitality
was great game you smoked in the third
map though and I said I'd do a shoot
[Music]
baki gone wind [ __ ] why not why not us
sure they got swept by a straws in the
finals but the fact that Australia made
it to the finals and it wasn't a
surprise is amazing for the region
itself obviously Australia is very
isolated from everyone else so you can't
build keep building and building whereas
in North America and Europe you have
America's huge Europe's huge and you
have a lot of different countries in
Europe and everyone's playing against
each other these play styles and
different and everyone's is growing
together whereas Australia is isolating
so far away sometimes in eSports we can
be far too focused on only the results
where the only thing that matters is
who's number one but sometimes we forget
to appreciate the grueling journey teams
go through to get to the top for a team
like a hundred thieves that journey is
what makes their success so satisfying
this hundred thieves Corps has overcome
a lot of different hardships to finally
put Australia on the map when it comes
to counter-strike and the best part is
these dudes are far from finished thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]